[Music]
yo hey what's happening is right man
we're doing it we doing it is going down
I'm the icing on the cake what is Isis
yeah I appreciate you so much for doing
this man this is really a this is it's
really an honor to be honest we'll go
ahead and just dive right in then yeah
I'd like to do it yeah let's not stress
it may his conversation we talking if
you could just say your full-name into
the microphone please right man rod man
yeah thank you for being on hot breath
buddy I breath yeah
Podcast yes so yes you had a podcast
world it's the new age I know I know man
I did a podcast a cymatic run on my
house okay okay it's a long way from the
Adam Carolla podcast I guess yeah yeah
he has a facility he has a facility
you've done everything up to this point
I have to ask first off is it true that
you didn't know you won last comic
standing until seeing it on TV that when
I didn't know who won particularly but I
can Anu like I would say a day before
because we had to go to the winner got
to go to do tonight's show but I still
didn't believe it didn't believe it even
though I was doing it tonight show and
then I went in and they had winner of
Last Comic Standing there and the show
was coming on that night I was in a
hotel room in New York by myself when I
when I seen the final and I fear that
believe that I had wanted but when I
seen it there to come down and say okay
I did that they were having a little
small hotel room in New York just it's a
Tonight Show so well you know start a
college so I knew someone still was
happening I imagine you got
calls after when a lot of towels and a
lot of you know just you can hear people
in the background just excitement so
that's that's what it been man it's been
like where you been it's like been
excitement so all around so I got I got
old people who used to know my earlier
stuff and then I got new people who
didn't know nothing about me so it's
been that kind of like refreshing thing
going on with me man ain't been doing
this for 20 years so it's it's I'm a I'm
a 20 year overnight sensation so yeah
any man yeah I mean 20 years in the game
is something a lot of people don't know
about you and you mean your resume is
impressive even before Last Comic
Standing but how did winning Last Comic
Standing change your career compared to
other accomplishments like HBO or a
Comedy Central special well it exposed
me to America
so it was uh it for me in America's
living room and I I see American because
I travel but you don't know who this
comedy I call it that good my company
who is it who is it affecting of who who
is enjoying it so you don't know that so
I know that's what we went out on tour
how big being on that network television
is because when we went to the show
they're like well you know we throw
these big houses on on tour and people
with people were throwing crazy and I
was closing all of them show you know it
was like uh yeah oh that's right man and
you know it yeah that's why I would like
to say too many pitches [ __ ] that
took so many pictures I'm pitch it out
right now picture Levites battle to so
like at a show now will people pay to
take pictures with you know I can't I
can't charge a fan you pay to come see
me I can I would not feel right about
that so no it's a is if I come out say
pitches we gonna be taking pitches try
to keep them self it to a minimum you
clearly not only had an impression on
America but also the network of NBC
because now you got a television show on
the horizon here
that's what they tell me Joe so we work
in with you know if that's a new world
and arena for me so I'm I'm a neophyte
in there in that world so I had you know
I had to learn that learn that world
because I can get the mic and get on
stage and do my thing there so uh you
know I tried ceramics I would just with
the TV people who've been in it you know
wonder gonna be one of the executives a
guy named Kenny Smith who did the game
but like now you're great writer so he
he was able to capture my voice and and
help me flesh out my story so I'm
looking forward to the man I think it's
gonna be a cool look so it said in Billa
rhythm said in Billa rippln down the
street yeah
was that something you even had on like
your to-do list or did they approach you
with the idea concept and already
written now this was this was something
you know I said about the show I never
was tripping about the the money portion
of it I was excited about the
development part of the deal the winning
the show I left oh you get to develop a
show yeah that was definitely on the
vision board to do that because I always
say stand-up is my tree but other things
should sprout from your tree so that was
one of the things that's okay I would
like that sprout from a tree because you
know out of the successful comedians
I've seen that's a natural progression
for them so you got a step you put in
that water just to see where they'd see
where you had in that world so because
it's gonna feed it's gonna be stand up
so though it's out and people everywhere
I went
when the show win show with show so I
was like yeah I don't know so - so when
it came time you go in and pitch your
idea I went through about ten write us
before I decided on a writer so that
that's a whole process so is a whole
nother world so it's a I'm excited by
that sound - and it's very
autobiographical I mean I think the
concept is really you moving from LA
back to Villa Rica to help out your mom
yes I would say autobiographical
which I was loosely based loosely made
so here you know you don't want to yeah
I'm a write the book and he outed our
stuff but yet it's it'll be based on my
company so if you like if you like my
company and the story that telling that
you're gonna you barely catch you you at
them on TV too you know a comedian
wanting a TV show is one thing but being
able to actually get the opportunity to
have one I mean I'm not sure where this
you're only the second Last Comic
Standing winner to get a TV show oh man
you just gave me a effect right there
because who was the first iliza
shlesinger now did it air addition to do
a pilot I think it aired but it was like
her hosting a show it's not like I guess
yours will be more like a sitcom like
multi I'm from the I'm from that mode
you know we come home and sit out on
Thursday night you know when we had them
good show zone so you know why it's a
wife and TV that's not the variety you
know people go to variety and those
things were offered that stuff that's
already being in place so you know they
can plug you right into that but I want
to come with some some little bit modes
and some some true that's true to my my
character I grow so I and I think
America a ticket there quality
entertainment you're saying yeah thank
good funny brought back yeah put some
certain ingredients in it season it
season it let it bar down yes they
inputted only play well you've been one
of the only comics from that show to get
a TV show I mean what do you think
you've been doing to stay relevant that
others may aren't funny
[Laughter]
whatever you think it is yeah yeah
anybody has in this in this comedy world
anybody that went anywhere has been
consistently funny so it ain't nowhere
around that so you no matter where you
put your funny act but it's gonna have
to be quality it's funny to you
have any any amount of success at all
and all that quality funny started right
in Atlanta a downtown club in a book
head second flow yeah
oh the old man yet oh and the first one
yes allow you to go down the stairs you
know yeah that's when they had
Blockbuster Video right behind that but
what was that experience like a man
who's always it was always cool cuz you
never you never knew when he was gonna
go up I started on like a Tuesday night
so I miss like this how many egg was a
big place and it uh sound was this new
club that just had a open that I learned
later about to see the comedy act sign
always at town so I guess somebody took
the comedy act sign and put it at Uptown
when they went out of business but uh it
was a you open mic night so just like
any comedian will start open mic night
Tuesday night earthquake was the host
and owner of the club no uh you know
that he would come in the show could be
I started he would come in and you know
it just grabs a mic there DJ hit him
with the hands and tell them get up on
stage get them off stage because I'm
about to go on stage he would go up and
crush but like Alan and you know you
signed up over mic you get there early
hoping to go on you don't know but you
know sometimes quake would go by the
listen some time he would just follow
the list up in his hand and and he
didn't know who he was gonna call and
he'll be nine hours just crushing
killing the room then he'll just call
you right man you're next and then you
had to go behind that so if you had to
you had to get funny you had be funny
cuz it strengthens you at that so it was
uh I felt like it was my beginning
stages the tough for me for comedy and
then we will go to a cloak out five five
nine right after that Bruce Bruce but
the host and that was that was a rough
room you could get booed at any time I
shot food uh shot so you know which way
it was gonna go so you know I've been
you know I've I've done that so it's
it's been a natural progression but yes
taste a funny man coming back to Atlanta
do you notice how far the scene has come
from those
old uptown days yeah because you know we
when I first down coming you know just
the beginning of have you seen a lot of
african-american act it was Neville's
getting their their shine yet def Comedy
Jam BT coming through so you know this
was when earthquake and Bruce Bruce and
Steve over the deficit when it was
coming becoming stars so increase truck
was right out of Atlanta so we say mos
def County Tammany would come back and
people would just go crazy and uh I got
my yoga Joe so you know he's right
that's it at the Friday so usually these
guys you know a lot a lot of you know
want to be Chris everybody want to be
Chris and then everybody want to be
quaking in their I want to be done to
secure those it was always trying to
find your style your voice and that's
that's that's a beautiful thing about
coming once you get that down you you
own your weight in were you primarily in
the urban side of the scene or would you
cross over as well I started urban I
started out of the way urban but uh I I
always knew my comedy would play
anywhere no you know when when I went to
a much knowledge that's for Laughs
comedy festival enough did that I think
it was like a three or something uh
that's when I kind of knew I said okay
this this thing is bigger so I started
you know placing myself in in in more
mainstream rooms and working it out and
getting getting better and still still
dimma urban rooms without comedy is just
is it has no I don't know why people try
to splice it because I mean if it's
funny it should work anywhere but some
people only cater to when you know some
people do only some people it's traded
Joe and some people probably you know
trader Joe and see a trader chill
products but uh let me set up a few
Friday you know I'm saying mm-hmm
cuz I'm a storyteller so stories work
anywhere yeah I'm so Beijing it yeah so
that's I always
new I can do come yet so I didn't I
didn't I just shot a box in yeah I
started urban and and and and now I
don't I guess I would be mainstream I'm
a mainstream well that's what they call
it I mean you know the it's mainstream
at urban and comedy is still segregated
for some reason but see that's where I
disagree I don't I think it has to be a
person of a punker my shows you come to
my shows it's it's not segregated now
some place I go is this is this gonna be
more of one race or whatever but you
come to my show it's like a melting pot
of America so that's what the show did
you had everybody watching no matter
what they background us in life was they
funny if you funny you don't capture the
masses people gonna come check it out
and that's you know that's my goal as a
comedian but there are times you know
I'll go and perform it uptown and be the
only white person in the entire building
yeah so that's I mean well I'm saying
that because that's exactly what I
thought I said I wanted to go to the
point early and I used to go sign up for
the punchline and they had like a
lottery but they would never I never
worn the lottery
I would never win the lottery so so as
it okay for me you go where you can get
some stage time so are you dealing with
that where where they will put me on
stage yeah yeah it's it's yes as much
stage time as possible right so that's
what you gonna need some stage that
right so they don't no matter where you
get stage time is you got you gotta find
it takes to get on and make some happen
well that must have felt good for you
not making the lottery a punchline but
then right after you win you're doing
like eight shows there yeah yeah I'm
going both died on you on that yeah I
see how to see how I work see I got a
beautiful man yeah yes that's also you
don't you know never never stop doing
your work cuz that's a club I used to
try to get into and didn't get on and
boom I'm selling out boom so beautiful
beautiful beautiful
can't plan that out no not long yeah
yeah and I was
say the Atlantic comedy scene is
stronger than ever
I'm not sure if you knew this this past
year we had eight comics on Last Comic
Standing six made it to the semifinals
and now we have one Clayton English in
the top five mm-hmm what would that mean
for comedy if Clayton wins because I
know you've mentioned in comedy they
only usually let one black guy quote
blow up at a time you read that
somewhere
oh yeah I saw an interview din where you
uh said that yeah I mean you know people
feel like we are pulled from the same
pool of people so but black people have
different tastes too so in in family and
in life we're not all the same so and I
just like any other white people
Asian people anything with if they're
all that same so they they have a
different groups of people and so I I do
feel like train hazard is a greatest
shot as anybody it's gonna be who's
gonna be funny is only like that's the
whole thing and I met him cuckoo cooler
dude always smiling so uh I'm expecting
them expecting big things big things
from me
how long were you in the scene before
moving oh I was that's why that's why I
built out my relationship so I was
probably 12 12 years in those people any
move so yeah and I always been back back
and forth too so that's always that's
home that's that's roots so I will
always have a love and an affection for
that cuz I can I can I can go there and
I know people don't come see that's why
I was able to do eight shows that at the
punch line and because my people don't
come I'll at me so I know that about
that so it's always gonna be it's gonna
be legit had family Union this weekend
so I got it you know that's that's my
people what made you want to move away
from your people because I was always
taught you got uh eventually you have to
mmsi on you gotta move to LA or New York
I know we're gonna go to New York I had
been there before a few weeks and did
the whole thing there
and uh you know being a being a country
boy southern boy that's a little I ain't
got time to get on all the training and
all he trained got to know that so I
know I'm not gonna do that I'm I like a
car I like to drive so when time came I
was just like uh cause you can you can
get caught in a people you should have a
deal you know you see how kind of story
when you should move but I always been a
risk taker so I just move when I felt it
was time to move and I knew it was gonna
be hard and I knew it was gonna be a
grind cuz I had a young family so uh you
know but you know we did our thing we
persevered so it's a that's a testament
of that but mostly income I in a move
back lemon I can't do it I can't do it I
can't do it so if you can make it as
excuse that you could say okay I'm gonna
take my lumps and do it my way and keep
you know have faith that uh things don't
turn and uh that's when like I'm
standalone I like boom and I was doing
my work so that's that whole thing so
you got to go where you can't always
look at other people in below Oh what
what happy for them because that person
was working you would not so that's rich
yeah and you were actually invited to do
Last Comic Standing yeah I was invited
when when it was something Noma OMA
vision that is something like that came
along because I know I need it I need it
it was time because I was feeling
feeling good by well with that mentally
and spiritually and all that this stuff
and it's funny I was I was on my plenty
and uh and uh they got to call and there
was a moment and I just said I said yes
and I didn't place me I had to audition
teach each round so it was there was no
there's no give me nothing and I had to
go out there and show what I can do and
uh and people like the judges acted
enough and that's that's how I went man
so it was I always say with my time I
went in with my blinders on and I you
know and focus on a goal so if they do
that you know it's the best man a woman
don't go always prevail did you move to
LA with any prospects or was it
just all vision visit and visit is
important you gotta have vision but yeah
I had a few leads and prospects so so
people can tell you one thing when you
show up it can become another thing but
I had a great person who probably I
could sleep on the flow and they let me
sleep on it slow and you know - I got my
sea legs and uh and uh you know it just
went from there just making the rounds
you don't you
you have prospect but you still got to
show you face if you've got to get to
know you and you got to go to these
auditions and you got to still try to
keep your old stuff going so it's um
then you got a you know it's it's a it's
a different world and where I'm from if
I can in both it's a different world
yeah oh yes but uh now it's a you have
to be able to adjust and be flexible man
that's that's and that's what kinda is
at what stage is you perform on stage so
I'm glad I can highlight something you
gotta be able to adjust and be flexible
and have something to go so it's so it's
that kind of place to me and if you if
you go down to that get the I how long
did you sleep on the floor for a year
and a half Wow yeah yeah yeah yeah oh no
no no yeah well I had a full time I had
a full time I moved up to a full time
nice but they had a dog and I like dog
but this particular values have passed
gas and that whole house for me yeah and
I didn't that appreciate that it out
yeah he ran away on one fourth of July
so while you're sleeping on the floor
slash futon are you doing open mics are
you getting in the clubs I'm getting
there I'm gonna flip at it you know I
had I was a road comedian so I would I
had a few gigs I could I could live you
know take care of what I needed to do
better sense but those dried up after a
while because people don't want to fly
here they budget this and
you know you're dealing with you're
dealing with as I could say thank you
promoters sometimes thank you for most
but most times you know that's going to
say if you kind of managing yourself you
ain't you know you're not got all the
way into the to the highly wouldn't
representations yet and I've had bad
managers that agents people promised mr.
inhabit so you you you you grow from the
old man so you gotta you know you gotta
know that's those things are gonna
happen along your journey you gotta keep
on turning again well another thing that
happens along the journey especially
Atlanta comedians is getting booed every
Atlanta comedian has a story of getting
booed what is yours you yeah yeah yeah
one say it deal eight years ago is
something about school they didn't
appreciate it but it wasn't a fool food
will reserve it was that good Quito and
I staged more Saturday it was more
combative than a whole food you've never
been just pull out boom now no no no no
no there's no reason that they ever
happy you might do a comment but yeah
you're not gonna boom is that that
wouldn't make any sense right there you
you you didn't come to let that go
answer but I know at the old uptown that
was almost a badge of out you could but
that's why I knew I got I was funny out
the gate that's what I was that's fine
at eight so what I I didn't have a no
boon I've seen cats who did struggle to
find that audience but I always had a a
few clips it's plenty going on folk so I
I just had to grow and mature in it but
uh and I'm still doing that but I
started funny
I would imagine something that
definitely had to mature is your
delivery yeah yeah there's nothing in
that ain't nag and say Oh fact is I do
not it is that
that's what that's what I do but I could
see starting out early and it may come
off as kind of like awkward and
confusing for people it could it could
be but it's it's and I always say some
jams and it kind of got to be a little
smart to it so it comes off as awkward
uh I don't know what people describe it
as I've heard it is it's uh I don't know
if you tell me everything about my
comedy but the propeller started a it's
funny though it's funny though so so I
don't try to analyze it I just I just
when they called my name
I thought that comedy Holy Ghost no I
get it I get to come the old it does not
- I do my thing you mentioned earlier
that finding finding your voice is
really when you start to make gains how
long did it take you to find yours I
don't know I don't have a talent and and
your voice should always be evolving oh
you know you because your comedy going
by so I would say I was I have a I have
a style of comedy I was I'm a
storyteller and I tell my stories in it
you know in a particular way and people
people appreciate it but no it's nothing
I I have to practice so to speak it's
trying to hone the crab man in rap I'm a
craftsman I'm a craftsman animart yeah I
look at company as art its art no your
artists paint some pitches show me
something did you always tell stories is
that something you evolved into I think
yeah yeah I've always been to each other
and I didn't know what it was Carl I had
it for me and uh
years ago named Tony tones he told me
like man you know you could talk about
anything he say because they're
listening to you cuz I didn't like the
silence that's why people like he don't
need to take a breath because I used to
talk the whole time and I was like uh I
gotta take a breath but he's like no it
don't matter he's like they they
listening to every word you say and it
is like every other words gonna be some
funny
in there so people up steal anything up
on here so I always felt like I was I
was doing something amazing but I didn't
know what what it was so so and now I
kind of get it a little bit more whether
what a funny lies so I I enjoy I enjoy
comedy that's the whole thing people
have fun in my show cuz I'm having fun
telling it to I'm enjoying it because
I'm present with the joke so you come to
my show that even if I'm telling the
story it's gonna be some different nits
in the store because it's I'm living
that story your story is be a little bit
little bit different and is that your
writing process with storytelling as you
go up and just tell a story and just
gradually hone it okay
that's right wait yeah and I'm always
trying to you know make it make that
story tighter you know in saying so it's
um it's definitely I would say that's my
writing process and I don't write per se
the whole whole thing I the concept is
that I want something I can write jokes
for jokes a joke but no I know if you
guys don't paper you like say I don't
know what the funny lies but let me go
tell it so I live a lie I live live I
don't live on paper really I live in
your face well that is the great thing
about your stories is that they are like
joke joke joke joke joke and a lot of
comics on Last Comic Standing you know
they're doing shorter bits just to get
jokes out but a testament to your
storytelling is that you're able to take
up your whole time on Last Comic
Standing with maybe one a story yeah
people yeah I think people copy that
this year but the goal is to be funny
joke you're right nothing
if you overthink it's in that's where
you go get in trouble with it so it's
like your first instinct is usually the
right one within we get caught up in you
know messing with it too much anything
and that's life you know we always so I
try to trust that boom that's best funny
boom that's funny if I find another
piece boom put that with if I find
another piece
don't put that way so now we just got
out of these little little boom boom
booms in the tails but it's I'm I'm
looking for funny out day I'm not that's
it that's my job I'm in find it business
I'm looking for funny out and back a
plan yes
I try to give it to the people and how
do you know when a moment in your life
is primed for like a joke because you're
talking about I mean really I mean like
a Seinfeld like precision on a moment in
your life and you're building a whole
universe around it for example all right
the self-checkout joke that's one of
your I would say most popular jokes and
it's just hilarious I mean on the
surface this is just you're at the
grocery store a lady says hey this aisle
is open you go over there and it's self
checkout and you have to do it yourself
and the computer asks for customer
service on the surface that's the story
but you're able to turn this into a
three-minute piece that is like laughs
laughs laughs laughs okay hey I like you
use word piece cause you'll you'll tell
me shouldn't be little pieces though
this in my favors man so I each each
story is my baby so I'm I'm into Stowe
and these things that are happiness
these things that happened to you they
happen every time I go to the store so
I'm trying to make sure I don't leave
any of what happens when we do any
stones we had to check ourselves out
what all is going because that's a
universe that's a scene they had
meetings about it and said people would
love to do this though you know how to
do that if they know that and so I'm
always trying to get to get to behind
the story then when I put myself in
situations it's like oh okay I see
what's going to say hello boss right you
sweet shop in your hand working here
okay okay so that's a committee got
together and decided that that's what
people would like to do when people
people love it so and I love it I'm
actually just a [ __ ] man no Maputo and
in fact as soon as it happens in the
middle of it are you like okay this
would be a good joke I think companies
listen
so yeah yeah uu is just special your
your life if you want to Devin to your
life you can do kind of but I think the
best County is always being when it's
when they had the personal touch to it
so he's Mitchell Seinfeld or the priors
or Eddie it always had a personal touch
to increase Rocko Chappelle's what
Carlin was you know it is like they they
had a passion about about this stuff so
it I guess a one world I would say it
come together you got out passion for it
yeah it's gotta be passionate that's
always gonna be believin with this
passion to fill I know you mentioned the
art of comedy so that's what I'm really
interested in is that comedic process
and I mean you you may go on stage and
tell the story about self-checkout but
then is it a year or so later where this
is like a bit that is laughs per line so
I'm from the school is no joke is truly
oh it's just you have to dust it out
sometime I'll polish it up now some
people live in the you know I gotta burn
this set I don't believe you have to
burn a sit I believe all jokes are
unfinished products if you in any be it
something you can't you can't use no
more but some bits live on as I've been
fortunate enough happiest that I've been
able to pull back that uh this disc is
still work and bring it up to date
oh you don't have new stuff happening so
it's just it's it's it's the process if
the process man I guess everybody your
practice like what that comedian which
you say you are I want to do everything
you know I want to be like you and have
you know my own TV show and have
creative control of my career I would
love to be a storyteller and that's why
I'm asking use because that's what I
struggle with right now is stepping out
and telling a story and it being funny
it could be interesting and they're
listening but I'm not getting you know
consistent laughs well that's you gotta
go back to the lab
yeah you get to go back to the lamprey
what what can we take out what can we
add with this story a working man so
that stuff could always be funny but you
it's funny got failed but you you got it
you gotta add some seasoning to it to
make it make it go yeah you create your
world that's you create your comedic
world man so you know what great people
great cuz they they do their own thing
they do it they way you make it sound so
easy I would say easy is what you
consider how are easy because everybody
level level of that is different so I I
don't know what you consider hard in
today you have to be honest with
yourself on some things and say okay do
I want to do I want to go down with it
cuz it's gonna be uncomfortable it's
supposed to be it's nobili uncomfortable
and being it it get comfortable then
it'll get funny because you comfortable
boom man we work a little fish grease we
plan with fish fries yeah now we're
cooking here so it yeah I loved it I
loved it I like this fast oh uh we can
get out of here yeah yeah I think we did
it yeah we're we're excellent all right
is there anything else you want the
world to know about rod man oh man just
uh I guess is mandatory to say follow me
on Twitter every time a company uh check
out my website where I met company that
get plenty I mean right man Connie calm
you know see where see where I'm coming
to a city near you man with a they just
find it so that's that's how we doing
and I appreciate I appreciate the love I
appreciate it letter that's probably
where more to the specially out
especially at man so uh we working
towards towards that so uh so uh you
know it's always always love and then
time you need me I'm oh I look back at
you man all right like you might look
brother yeah I feel like it's my little
brother now well we learned
and I appreciate your time rod man I'd
oh to be the keep keep keep it funny
keep it funny okay no other won't know
it's late I have it famine all right
[Music]